bye
i'd like to
call the fiscal committee to order
at uh 10 a.m
uh we have this is a special meeting
we have one item on the agenda
and that is to uh
we made several suggestions on the
ydc settlement process
and um
i'd like to call uh
general formella forward
and ask him to please
identify the things that he's changed
and
um
we'll we'll go from there so if i could
well thank you and good morning madam
chair members of the committee
for the record john formella attorney
general
and appreciate the opportunity to be
so last time we were here about a month
ago
um i i went through
in quite a bit of detail the the
documents
before you um that set up the claims
process and and settlement guidelines
for the ydc settlement fund i thought
what would be helpful this morning is to
to walk through the changes we've made
um after our discussion with the
committee on august 10th and also after
our discussions that we've had with
claimants council since the last meeting
most of the documents are the same but
we've made some some key changes that i
want to walk through and then i'm happy
to
to take questions either on the changes
or of course on any of the substance of
the documents
so what we did after the last meeting we
we went back and we first cataloged all
of the comments we got from the
committee just to try to make sure that
we had captured all of the feedback
um that you all had provided to us and
we also have had some pretty extensive
conversations with with claimants
council
not specifically with nixon peabody
they they've generally chosen not to
engage in the process but we have had
some very productive conversations with
other claimants council
since since the last meeting and i think
that we have reached a good compromise
on some changes and i think that
you know i feel comfortable sitting here
today telling you that we have an
indication both from claimants counsel
who have written letters to the
committee and also other claimants
counsel
who may not have written letters but
have indicated that they have clients
who they believe will participate in
this process i think the general
feedback
from many of the claimants council out
there is that this process is not
perfect and we of course would never
claim it would be but
we believe that many claimants counsel
now feel that this will be workable for
many clients who are out there
so that that is generally i think where
we sit here today but i will walk
through some of the
some of the specific changes we've made
actually before i do that one thing i
also want to add is that we've had
productive discussions with claimants
council about who the administrator
might be and while you know we're not
prepared to name names publicly today
i think that we have a good
understanding between our office and
claimants council on who would make a
good administrator and i'm confident
that if this process is approved we will
be able to come to agreement on who the
administrator will be very quickly and i
think that will be important as this
process moves forward if it gets
approved because once this committee
approves this process
if the committee approves the process
and once the administrator is appointed
the administrator will sort of take
control of this process and it will be
the administrator who
can come back to request changes from
the committee i think that's an
important thing to keep in mind as we
walk through the documents today because
the administrator
will be
i think seen by many claimants as a more
neutral party
and so
the fact that the administrator will
sort of take control of this process and
take control of requesting future
changes should give some comfort to
those who who may still feel that there
are some tweaks that can be made as we
go forward and as we see how this
process is implemented
so with that i'll walk through the
changes we've made since the last
meeting
the first overall change we made based
on i think feedback from representative
emmerich was to split the documents into
separate documents
uh it was always our intention for these
documents to be presented to claimants
as separate documents but i think
presenting them to the committee as
separate documents is helpful in seeing
what this looks like if each document
stands on its own
so last time we had three documents that
were packaged together
you now have four documents in front of
you because we added a notice document
based on feedback that we got at the
last meeting i'll walk through that when
i get to it but i thought it would be
most helpful to walk through the
so the first document that you have in
this as we discussed last time is the
claims process document
as we talked about at the last meeting
the claims process document is really
meant to be
sort of the the governing document for
for the settlement process it's the
rules of the road if you will
so
the claimant themselves will not have to
go through and digest the claims process
document the claims process document is
really for the administrator and the
attorneys who are involved
because it's it's the rules or put
another way the law that will govern the
settlement process
when and if it's approved
so we made a couple changes to this
this document not anything major because
most of the feedback was on other
documents but the first change
that we made
based on feedback at the last meeting
this is the section of the process
regarding notice to claimants of what
their options are after they get a
proposed award from the aeg designee
if the claimant does not
agree
with the ag designee's position or
proposal
or actually i should say when the
claimant gets the ag designee's position
or proposal
the claimant has the option of accepting
that position
um of requesting that the
the process go to the administrator so
that a proceeding be scheduled in front
of the administrator
and then the third option the claimant
has is to withdraw their claim from
further processing and we just wanted to
make clear that if that happens the
claimant can then proceed with any
pending litigation
the reason this clarification was
important is that if a claimant enters
this process
and they've already filed a lawsuit they
would have been required to sign an
agreement to stay that lawsuit while
they go through this process so we
wanted to make clear that as part of
option three as part of withdrawing
their claim from this process they can
continue with their litigation so we
just clarified that at the top of page
10.
another clarification we made in the
claims process document and we made this
clarification throughout the various
documents
and this is where we defined
former ydc resident we just wanted to
make clear that
a current resident
is considered a former ydc resident for
purposes of the statute
because the statute defines a ydc
resident as someone who resided at ydc
so for example if someone on a say a
current ydc resident on a tuesday claims
they suffered abuse either earlier that
day or the day before they they fall
into this definition and so they they
could use this
process and then there's one additional
change we made this was based on
discussion with claimants council and i
apologize i went out of order but this
it's about the middle of page 16 section
27. this is the language that deals with
attorneys fees and costs we wanted to
just simplify this language a bit
um
the statute provides that the the
the top attorney fee award can be no
more than 33.3 percent
and rather than have a number of factors
that the administrator weighs we just we
figured it would be easier to note that
the administrator can take into account
a fee agreement that a
claimant might have with their lawyer
and that the administrator should just
review an attorney fee request to ensure
that it complies with new hampshire rule
of professional conduct 1.5 because that
that rule already governs attorneys um
governs attorneys on on what fee they
might take especially if it's a
contingency fee and that rule is meant
to ensure that that fees are reasonable
so we thought it would make more sense
to tie that type of review
to rule 1.5 than to try to have some
you know different standard that might
be separate from that or have factors
that are separate from that
so those are the changes we made in the
claims process document
again this these were based on feedback
from the committee and also feedback
from
the next document that you have in front
of you is a new document and it's fairly
short
but this is
fis-22-308
and this is an additional document we
added
at the last meeting of the fiscal
committee and based on conversations
with claimants council we received
feedback that
we really needed to beef up
the notice section a bit to make sure
that we were we were going to be doing
everything we can that the administrator
would do everything they can
to provide notice to any potential
claimants that might be out there
so this document what this document does
is provide guidance to the administrator
on providing notice to potential
claimants
and it covers mechanisms that were
already covered in the statute
so the mechanisms that were already
covered in the statute were notice in
newspapers notice on social media
postings at correctional facilities
press releases and website postings
and based on discussions with claimants
counsel
and based on discussions discussions at
the last fiscal committee meeting we
talked about how it would also be
helpful to post notice
in courthouses and in clerks offices
in community mental health center
centers and where we can in private
offices of mental uh private mental
health practitioners
so the idea being that we want to try to
cover any potential place where
someone who who might be a potential
claimant that would go through this
process
so we expect that the administrator will
also
you know when when that person is
appointed we'll take a look at this and
frankly may come up with even additional
ideas of where we would post notice but
we wanted to give them as much guidance
as we could so we added this document
this document also
helps to just sort of highlight how
important notice is because at the end
of the day we could have the best
process
in the world and if people don't know
about it if potential claimants don't
know about it it's not going to be
helpful to them
we also recognize that
you know after so many years
and when we're dealing with such a large
number of potential claimants that you
know we can't make any assumptions about
the circumstances
the current circumstances of a potential
claimant who's out there someone could
find their cell find themselves at this
point in any number of life
circumstances and we want to take that
into account when we're trying to make
sure we cover all our bases with
so that is document
fis-22-308
representative edward you have a
question uh yes ma'am thank you um so uh
mr attorney general um
is
what would be the process in a few years
if um somebody who had wanted to file a
claim or had an argument that they
should file a claim if they if they find
these notices inadequate is there is
this appealable is this um
something that they can come back and
say that we were negligent on this is
probably pretty comprehensive but i'm
just curious what their
recourse and what the outstanding risk
would be to the state
i
you know the the statute that was passed
provides a deadline of december 31st
i think that if someone
didn't get the notice
their recourse really would be to to
come back and make an and the deadline
had passed i think their recourse would
be to make an appeal to the legislature
to extend the deadline
or to
to bring their claim in court i don't
see a lot of exposure for the state on a
claim that we didn't do a good enough
job providing notice of what's
essentially an alternative dispute
resolution
process but it will absolutely be our
goal to
to make the notice so widespread that if
someone doesn't file a claim it won't be
because they didn't know about it it
would be because they decided not to
so the next document you have in front
of you
again now is a separate document is
fis22-309
this document
is
the guidelines for valuing claims
so in this document we made a couple of
of significant changes
based on our discussions with claimants
council and i believe that
these changes will represent a good
compromise on how to value these claims
and and these changes are sort of key
or a key piece of getting a number of
these claimants counsel on board with
feeling that this process would work for
so the first the first change is one
i've already mentioned but i'll just
note that it also appears
in the guidelines um and it appears in a
couple different places but this again
is the definition of former ydc resident
so there are a couple of places in this
document on pages three and seven
specifically that we again are just
clarifying that a current resident who
might be in ydc now or in the sununu
what's now the sununu center now
would be considered a former ydc
resident for purposes of the statute and
the next change
this is near the top of page nine but
this is in the frequency multiplier
table
in the first draft of this process that
we brought before you you'll recall that
uh
sort of the the
range if you will of number of incidents
spanned all the way from 1 to 25 or more
and the multiplier went from 1 to 15.
based on discussion that we had at the
last committee meeting and discussions
we had with claimants counsel
we've we've had a lot of
a lot of exchange about the need to
recognize
that
you know for someone who suffers sexual
or physical abuse
you know there may be a difference
between one incident and two incidents
but once you get beyond one
uh based on the harm and the trauma that
you suffer it really is necessary to
to not require so many incidents in
order to get to the top the top of the
range as far as the value of settlements
goes
given that the cap
in this process is 1.5 million
i think everyone recognized that that
it's also important to
to have
some recognition that those who may have
suffered more incidents of abuse
should get more compensation to a point
than than someone who suffered less
incidence of abuse so those were the two
considerations we were trying to balance
when coming up with
when we had a were initially discussing
this process before we even brought the
first draft to you
we had had a proposal from from certain
claimants council that
the frequency multiplier table
go from only one to eight so with one
incident you got a certain multiplier
once you hit three incidents you got the
next highest multiplier and then once
you
that it only required eight to get to
the highest multiplier
we had put that out to
to sort of the full universe of
claimants council and we didn't get
feedback one way or another on that at
the time and so that was why we decided
to bring our original proposal to you
which had the wider range
based on the committee's feedback and
based on the discussions we've had with
claimants council since
i think we have arrived at a good
compromise
that that i think many claimants counsel
generally support
and and
that many claimants counsel
see
and it makes them feel that this this is
a process that will work for for many of
their clients and that is the frequency
multiplier you see before you now
um it spans from
from one incident
it's the bottom category the top
category is 10 or more
and the multipliers step up 1 3 7 and
12.
so i think what this does is balance
it recognizes the fact that
values of settlement should should step
up quicker
based on a smaller number of incidents
but that there also should be some range
between
you know one incident in 10 or more so
that we are
we're giving recogni you know we're
recognizing from a value perspective the
fact that you know say seven or eight
incidents are more harmful than than one
as i've said repeatedly throughout this
process there really is no perfect way
to do something like this you know
there's no
amount of money that really compensates
someone for for experiencing sexual or
physical abuse
and there's never going to be a perfect
way at which you can arrive at
at a value
um
or a way to to value
compensation that someone should receive
for for that type of harm
what we tried to do with this is
put a lot of thought into it have a lot
of conversations
think about all the considerations at
play and arrive at
at a compromise that does the best we
can to balance the different
considerations that are there and i i
think this table does it and i think
that is reflected in the letters that
you will have received from claimant's
counsel
and it's reflected in conversations
we've had with other claimants counsel
who while they they were not comfortable
sending a public letter
um they they indicated that their their
clients or many of their clients they
thought would participate in this
process
so that is that's probably the most
major change made in in the
in the guide the valuation guidelines
the other thing you'll notice is that we
no longer have two separate tables for
sexual abuse and physical abuse this
revised frequency multiplier table
applies to both sexual abuse and
a couple of other changes we've
we've made
when it comes to valuing settlements
were we're based again on discussions
with claimants council
the first one i'll point out
well they're both on page nine but the
first one i'll point out is down in
these are the aggregate aggravating
and this
this first change
is on the value
of the aggravating factor associated
with photographs or video recordings
that might have been taken during an
incident of abuse
as we've talked about this with
claimants counsel we we have talked
about the fact that for someone who
suffers abuse
the fact that that photos or video might
is something that can sort of cause
continuous trauma because if you have
suffered abuse even if it's years and
years ago if you have reason to think
that there are of their photos or videos
that exist of that abuse you live in
constant fear that those photos or
videos could could resurface and
and that
that sort of causes a continuous trauma
continuous harm from the abuse you've
suffered even if it's decades ago so
we've increased this aggravating factor
from fifty thousand dollars to a hundred
the other change we made
here is in the
the aggravating factor that is
associated with the duration of abuse so
the amount the length of time during
which someone might have suffered abuse
it's near the top of the page
but what we've done in the original
proposal
uh the course of conduct would have had
to continue for 24 months for this
aggravating factor to come into play
we've reduced that period from 24 months
to 12 months
based on discussions with claimants
counsel and we've increased the
so again this is
i think this is another change that came
out of what were were very um
thoughtful and and productive
conversations with claimants council
about different things we needed to
recognize
when it comes to valuation
the last
but this was the section
related to issues of credibility
in in the last version of of this
document we had a sentence that said
that you know statements made by a
claimant made under oath and notarized
would be would
we would presume them to be credible
unless shown otherwise
um with that statement we were just
trying we were trying to reflect
that
you know we would not assume any
claimant who comes to this process is
not telling the truth we would treat
every claimant with respect and dignity
but based on discussions with the
committee
and looking back at the legislative
history
i mean we ultimately determined that we
we did not need to have that sentence in
there and really should not have it in
there because
um it would lead to a concern that we
were say shifting the burden of proof
from the claimant to
to the state
and
you know also in looking back at the
legislative history there were specific
discussions about that issue and the
language regarding treating every
claimant with respect and dignity was
was put in there i think specifically as
a as a way to reflect that value without
having language that sounded like it
would be burden-shifting and so we
ultimately determined based on feedback
from the from the committee and looking
back at the legislative history that
that sentence really should come out so
we've pulled that sentence out of this
section
i think
you know these documents still
absolutely reflect the value that we
will treat every claimant that comes to
this process with respect
with dignity will listen to their
stories take in their information
certainly not assume anyone is not
telling the truth but at the same time
it's important not to
not to have language in there that looks
like it's a burden uh a language it
kind of the the final major change that
we we made to
the last document that you have in front
of you
and this is the
the claim packet which includes the
claim form
and the worksheet
um we've tried to make a number of
changes here to
to make this
more accessible to victims of slash
claimants
and to
to make it more user friendly
and to make it even clearer that
you know we recognize that any victim
or claimant will come to this process in
a different situation in different
circumstances
with perhaps different capacity to
really grapple with
a document that no matter how we try to
simplify it is going to be
somewhat complicated just because we are
dealing with
with frankly complicated issues but we
have tried to
to make it as simple as we can
the first thing we've done based on
feedback at the last committee meeting
was just to improve the line spacing so
where
you'll just notice where that there's
there's a section for writing in
content we've tried to improve that line
spacing
i do think that
you know it's important to remember that
in many cases someone might just attach
additional sheets so they may not rely
on what's here to to write in what they
want to write in they may have a
separate piece of paper where they write
they write additional information but
we've at least
tried to widen that spacing out so it
looks a little more
it just is easier to get get the writing
in
we have also throughout this document
based on feedback from the committee
and again we've had discussions about
the the deadline for submitting claims
we've just tried to add and highlight um
the notice about what the deadline is to
submit your claim in various places so
you'll see that throughout this document
i won't
you know turn to every place where that
appears but we've
tried to put a black box around it tried
to put it in more places so that it is
very clear
what what the deadline is it's december
at the last committee meeting and in
discussions with with claimants council
and our victim witness advocates victim
witness specialists
we had a lot of discussion about the
you know this issue of what what is
required versus what is optional
and ultimately
the way we've tried to address that here
is to set this up so that that no
information is required that we make it
clear to claimants that the more
information they submit the better um
that
that certain information may eventually
be required obviously we will need to
know someone's name we'll need to have
sufficient identifying information but
that that a claimant should just put in
to this form as much information as they
can
and that
not only is assistance available but
also once a form is submitted if the
administrator determines that additional
information is needed the administrator
will contact the claimant and work to to
what we've really done here is
is put this in the hands of the
administrator who will be the third
party neutral it will ultimately be up
to the administrator to take a look at
what's submitted and make determinations
as to what additional information is
needed
i think that is a good way to balance
the need to collect information with the
need to make this accessible to victims
ultimately in my mind it is
it is actually helpful to a claimant or
a victim
to ask for certain information even if
we're not going to require it because
what we're doing when we do that is that
we're providing we're providing sort of
the guide posts and and the direction as
as to what information
will make their claims stronger will
strengthen their ability to get a higher
award i think that asking for that
information is
is i would submit is helpful to
claimants and actually makes this victim
friendly
but we do recognize that that we need to
provide
a fair amount of flexibility in what we
would require to be submitted and so
while we
i think what we've achieved here by
making
this information generally optional is
we have given
um
some guideposts and a roadmap
for a claimant on what is helpful
and what will help them strengthen their
claim without requiring them to submit
it to have their claim processed and so
it really
it gives the claimant options as to how
much they want to bring forward and it
puts the discretion in the hands of the
administrator who will be the neutral
party in this process to determine
you know what might be missing and what
they need to go back and ask for
so that that's reflected in a couple
different places in this document you
first see it on page two
where we
take out any reference to required
information and just ask that a claimant
do their best to provide as much
where
even for some of the required
identifying information
we note that that might eventually be
required but it's not going to be
required in order for
their a claim to be taken in and for the
review to begin and for the
administrator um to take a look at it
and begin the process
of reaching back out to the claimant if
necessary to collect identifying
information
again there there's there's some basic
things that we will need
eventually
for a claimant if they submit a claim
and and money's going to be paid out on
that claim we'll need to make sure that
we know who that person is we'll need to
make sure that we can confirm it but we
want to make this as user friendly as
possible and we want to make it clear
that
this process will be set up in such a
way that everything possible will be
done to assist someone in providing the
necessary information so giving them
guidance on what information is helpful
and also giving them assistance on on
collecting it
we certainly don't want the collection
the need to collect information to be
so those are really
these changes just kind of appear
throughout the packet but those are
really the the major the major change
made to the claim packet
is setting it up so that it's the
information is optional
in the worksheet which again is is an
optional tool for a claimant i'll just
note that we have um
again made the changes necessary to
to align with the fact that the
multiplier is now going to look
different
and made the changes necessary to align
with the fact that
um the aggravating factor for
photographs or video is is now up to 125
thousand dollars
and
the duration
the change to sort of uh the aggravating
factor for the conduct occurring over
the over a period of time has been we've
reduced that time period from 24 months
to 12 months and increased the
multiplier from 0.25 to 0.5
you'll see those two changes on pages 8
and 9
so again they're just identical changes
that were they're identical to the chain
the same changes we made in the
in addition to the
or i should just say just to kind of sum
up
i would say you know there aren't a
large number of changes to what we
presented last time but i think the
changes that were made were some very
key changes
the multiplier table was was a very i
think fundamental change made to the
valuation
guidelines that
addressed
perhaps the most significant concern we
heard from many claimants council out
there regarding
requiring less incidents to get to the
top value
and then
shifting the the packet and the
worksheet from required information to
information that's all optional
i i think
really goes a long way to addressing the
concern that the
claim form and the worksheet is too
complicated
again there there was no
i think there was no way to really put
together the the claim packet
and the form
without
having a number of questions and
requests for information and then the
reason again for that is that by asking
those questions and showing claimants
what information will be helpful to them
we're actually giving them a road map to
to what can lead them to potentially
higher settlement value
but by making that optional we're not
requiring that all of that information
be submitted and we're not
ending up in a situation where
having to answer a large number of
questions submit a large number of
information at the outset
ends up discouraging someone from
participating in the process or or
coming into the process in the first
place
so i i think the changes we've made here
again while they're not they're not a
large number of changes they're they're
significant changes that make this
process both more accessible
and also address the most fundamental
concerns i think we heard from many
claimants council about how we're we're
we also had submitted to you a letter
from the department of corrections and
commissioner hanks was was kind enough
to take the time to appear before you
today to answer questions
with regard to how how a resident at one
of our
one of our facilities might interact
with this process
so the department of corrections did
submit a letter to you that just
outlined
um
the process they would use for providing
notice of something like this to
residents and that letter discusses the
the tablet method residents do have
access to tablets and also closed
circuit television and that letter noted
that notice could be published even on a
weekly notice of this process could be
published even on a weekly basis
and that the department of corrections
would work with the administrator once
that person is appointed on the language
of that notice
the department of corrections letter
also noted that residents
have access to facility libraries and
it's through those facilities that they
usually
or they usually use those facilities to
contact council
and the department noted in their letter
that they could make the list of
available attorneys
or or the published list of attorneys
they could make that available
through the tablet system
the department also noted in their
letter that residents who litigate have
access to notaries through assigned
counselors and case managers and that
notary services would continue to be
available to residents
and that residents have access to a
phone system
the department did note that the
administrator would need to be able to
take accept collect calls but i'm sure
we can work with the administrator
to to make that happen
the one thing the department did note is
that residents do not have access to to
in the internet
and i um and that's something that would
not change with this process
but
i think as the department notes in their
letter there are a number of other tools
that can be made available to ensure
that residents will will have access
to getting their claim forms in and it
we may be able to work with the
department of corrections to to find
some way to allow some type of
electronic interaction with
with this
with this process but
we'd have to have further discussion
about that with the department and we'd
have to of course balance
the need to make this accessible to
residents while not
um not making any fundamental changes to
current restrictions the department of
corrections has in place
because i i'm confident that there are
very good reasons for
for why the department of corrections
has things set up the way they have it
currently set up so the commissioner of
corrections is here again to answer any
further questions on that if the
committee has questions but i just
wanted to outline what the department
had provided in their letter
in addition to
the changes i've just noted here we did
you know also try to go through these
documents and make any type
typographical errors um i'm hoping we
caught all of them
if we i think there were a couple that
we missed that representative lin has
already pointed out but
make sure that those are
if the committee would permit us to make
only typo type corrections not anything
else
so we have not asked for
permission to make you know
non-substantive changes or anything like
that
i would propose that the committee
give
the department of justice um
the authority only to make what would be
what would be typographical corrections
so that we can address any
any typos that we might find but
we can also bootstrap that with the
administrator if the administrator finds
any more significant tweaks that are
needed the administrator once that
person is appointed will have the
authority to come back to fiscal and ask
for those changes and as i mentioned
earlier i think that
the administrator coming back to ask for
those changes probably gives even more
comfort to claimants because the
administrator will be
will be the the objective third party in
this process
with that those are those are the
changes we've made
i just want to say i really appreciate
the conversation we had at the last
meeting i think we got a lot of good
feedback we had some really good
discussion on how to make this process
better
i really appreciate the conversations
we've had with claimants council
especially since the last meeting i
think we had very thoughtful and
productive discussions i want to
particularly recognize senior assistant
attorney general jen ramsey who you all
know who is here today i think she has
done an excellent job in really taking
the lead in in facilitating those
discussions she's spent hours
hours with these guys really trying to
to find solutions where we can
to again make this process one that is
not perfect
it will not work for every claimant but
i think what you have before you is a
process that can work for many claimants
many victims
and and give give them at least an
option that is far more
victim-centered and trauma-informed than
traditional litigation i think that's
reflected in the letters that you've
received from some claimants counsel i
think that's also reflected in the
indications we've gotten from claimants
counsel who while they haven't submitted
a letter do believe that they have many
clients who can use this process
so with that i'm happy to take any
questions
are there any questions from the
committee
represent
lynn thank you madam chair um yes i uh
first of all i want to say i think dude
i i i think you have done an outstanding
job in this um
the uh
i i have no i have really no
uh substantive to the issues and with
regard to the to the typo kind of things
i mean that's just that that that
it's entirely
it's it's it's very easy to see how that
kind of thing could happen and i
personally i don't know why the rest of
the committee i have no problem at all
with saying that non-substantive
typo correction kind of things can be
should be able to be done
um if i could though i'd like to ask
just a couple of questions
um and i refer specifically to fis
309 which is the
guidelines
um
and in particular um
my understanding i base my this question
on a discussion i had with attorney
scolambrini who i see in the back of the
room and i think you've probably
discussed it with him also
one of the things that he points out and
i think it's a fair
point to make although
i'm not quite sure what the i'm not
suggesting that necessary that changes
have to be made i'm not suggesting that
but i do think it's something that ought
to be sort of
on the record so to speak and something
that the administrator ought to take
into account
is that um in the categorization of um
the levels of abuse
i'm on page
five
of uh
in the in the categorization of
of abuse
um well and actually i should say maybe
because it also goes back to page two
um
the
key point attorney solembrini points out
i think correctly that there
at least arguably could be
um
situations in which
the abuse in which
sort of a similar level of abuse
of a male victim versus a female victim
might be treated differently and what in
particular what he points out is that
in terms of
digital
abuse of a female it's almost any
touching of female genitalia is very
likely to involve some kind of
penetration which would bring it into
category a
whereas with a male victim
[Music]
a touching of let's say a touching of a
male penis would not involve it would
not involve penetration which there
would therefore mean that it would be in
category c
and depending on the circumstances those
could there could be it's easy to
imagine situations in which
the the that the same sort of level of
abuse would be treated differently i'm
not sure there's a
good answer to that but i think it's
something that the administrator
you know ought to take in mind perhaps
in evaluating in evaluating individual
claims um i don't know if you had any
comment on that
yeah i i think i would i would agree
that that that is something the
administrator could take into account
and and to the extent you know i i don't
have any
changes that i feel like i could sit
here and comfortably say i i think would
address that that would be appropriate
but
i i would say i would again kind of
say that the administrator
once that person is appointed would have
the ability to come back to this
committee and and request changes and
there may through further discussion be
be something that could be developed on
that front but we did discuss that issue
with attorney scolombrini and we were
not able to arrive at any
changes that we thought could could
address that issue but but i i certainly
the point was was taken and i think it's
something that
deserves potential future or further
consideration all right let me ask one
question and then the other thing this
is this is it's a little bit different
but somewhat related you may recall that
that i had asked a question um the last
time about whether
um there was
there was really any difference
with regard to i'm back on page two
between
uh
category c intimate sexual touching
parenthesis masturbation and then d
other touchings and i think miss ramsey
correctly pointed out that there is a
difference in the definitions in the
guidelines and i and i i completely
agree with the definite distinction
she's pointed out um
but
what
what that's what that does
doesn't completely address is that
they're now
there are overlaps
c and d in other words there's some
things that could be categorized either
as falling into d
or falling into c and i again assume
that the admit that
that you know whether it falls into d or
c in some sense would involve
the the administrator determining how
how significant was this
particular incident of abuse and that is
i mean is that your understanding also
yes i i think that's
you know yes i think that's an area
where the administrator will will just
have to make some determinations based
on the specific facts of a case
thank you
and then
i'm sorry just the only thing i want to
point out was just the uh the
i saw the typos if that's if that's okay
um so i guess i would say um in terms of
uh
on again on on document 22 309
um the um
the typos that i think need to be
oh no i'm sorry
should be on 310 i'm sorry uh fs
fis 22 310
think that
typos that need to be corrected are on
uh in the in the num number three
um
it says how old were how old you were
uh
i think the first you should go or maybe
um and then on page
the worksheet one
yeah the worksheet one yeah um i think
there
um
it it it says
we're talking about category c
but the lines say right in category a
and it really really
in the first line it should be write the
number of incidents of category c the
second line should say write the number
of incidents of category d rather than b
the third one write the number of
instances of category e rather than c
and then the next line down add
incidence of d and e i think that's i
think that's right that's
simple
uh and i think there was one more that i
pointed out to miss ramsay but just uh
oh in the on page uh
the next to last page in the uh notice
of filing
again i think there's just a typo on the
second line there where it says uh
the word for is there but shouldn't be
there should i have filed a claim with
the administrator i think so there's
just an extra word there other than that
um as i say i think this is uh
i think you guys have done an
extraordinary amount of work and it's uh
it looks
it looks very good to me and i plan to
vote yes to accept it
are there any further questions uh
senator rosenwald thank you madam chair
i do have a few questions
um
good morning thanks for being back here
um first i'd like to ask how much you
expect
to pay both the administrator
and the private law firm that you've
hired out of the fund i'm wondering how
much money will actually be
available after those expenses to settle
claims
so the
the administrator is
can be a part-time or full-time employee
and paid at this at the same salary or
no more than a superior court judge i
believe is what the statute says so
and so if if the administrator's
full-time they'll probably be paid
around the same salary as a superior
court judge if they're part-time they'll
be paid at whatever that same rate would
be
so calculate that out to be an hourly
rate they'll be paid around that rate
the judicial branch may need to
hire additional staff
to help the administrator which would
come out of the fund
so
you know superior court judge i believe
makes around 170 180 000 a year
then if you add in benefits
i think it would be a few hundred
thousand dollars for administrator and
their staff i don't expect to be more
than a million a year but probably in
the hundreds of thousands per year
and then as far as the
outside counsel we've retained for
the
the settlement process
i don't expect that that would be more
than a million dollars a year
um
it's gonna sort of depend on
how many
how many claims we get in
and what this really looks like as we
ramp up but we have not
i don't expect that we would spend more
than a million dollars a year on outside
assistance and even that is i'm not
saying that we think it would approach a
million a year but to give you an
estimate that with some certainty i just
want to be very so total of up to four
million
between the administrator
and the law firm because it's a two-year
process
yes okay so um thank you can i thank you
let's let me just let me just say one
thing on that it may go longer than two
years
because two years is the application
process
and so if someone applies
in december of
24 that may in fact run a little bit
longer right or you know some amount of
time so
i i think that
the attorney general is is correct that
we're probably looking at four million
even though
it could be more than two years right
okay and we'll of course try to keep
that number as low as we
of course
um so the last time you were here you
told us
that you had in mind
an average maximum award of
uh between six and seven
hundred thousand dollars or in other
words less than fifty percent of the
statutory cap
um
and that you made the multipliers and
aggravating factors
work to achieve that are you still
imagining
that average maximum award of 700 000
with your revision
i think what i would say to that is that
that's always been a very
rough
calculation so
you know when we were going through the
legislative process
as part of
figuring out what the caps and the
legislation would be we did we did the
research to try to determine an average
settlement award amount for similar
claims around the country and that's
that ended up around 700 000.
that was just one factor in the
in the original document we submitted to
you is trying to stay roughly within
that range give or take even
a hundred thousand or maybe even a
little more
um
i don't think the changes we've made
will
will fundamentally alter that
but that's also again because it was
based on some pretty rough calculations
and based on only some information about
some claimants
it's certainly not not an exact
science can i continue
yes you may please thank you ask just go
ahead and ask all your questions based
on all the information you've
reviewed internally what do you think
the median
award will be and what do you think
the most frequent
it's
i apologize senator but i really don't
think that's an estimate i can give you
because even the estimates we can give
would be based on
just looking at
say a spreadsheet list of numbers of
incidents that
that claimants might allege but
it's really not going to be until we
until
we have individuals who
who tell their stories and really tell
us
more details about what happened to them
and we have more details about the
information they have surrounding what
happened to them
it's not going to be until we get that
that that we could start to
determine what what those numbers might
look like there's there's still just a
lot we we don't know
you know this is a opportunity to remind
everyone of the the parallel process
we've got going on the criminal side
where we're doing the criminal
investigation
you know we have looked deeply into
allegations on the criminal side that
are within the statute of limitations
and where we think we might be able to
bring criminal charges with many many
people who would be outside of that
statute of limitations and so we haven't
we haven't conducted
a full criminal investigation so we just
have less details for that
that population we also only have we
have some details about some of the
claimants on the civil side less details
about others
there's there's enough left that we
don't know that i'm just not able to
give you a good answer to that these are
very what we've been able to give so far
are very rough estimates when it comes
to averages but when it comes to median
and what would be the most common number
it's just it's unfortunately not
something i can estimate i just wonder
because
we need to think how far this
100 million dollars or 94 96 million
is actually going to go it seems like
your department would have
been able to look at
all of the
alleged
come up with these numbers based on
where you think it's going to land but
um
in another
area i know that
you've changed the frequency multipliers
and it looks when i see your spreadsheet
that
it would
take 10
genital anal or oral rapes to hit the
cap
there's a big jump between nine and ten
rapes it's still a lot of rape
um
and under your
new
duration multiplier going from 24 months
to 12
victims hit would hit that cap sooner
if the rapes occur over a longer period
of time
but
even going back 10 years which was
all the information i could get out of
the child protection division
the average length of stay
for committed youth was only seven
months so
the shortened duration
looks good on paper but it's not likely
to be applicable to the majority of
claimants so
i'm i'm really wondering and struggling
with
why
you would award
more money to someone who
had been repeatedly raped over a longer
period of time
than over a shorter period of time
because
it seems counterintuitive and i'm
wondering what the department's
yeah i think there's a there's a couple
issues in there so i'm going to try to
hit all of them and if i miss any please
just thank you feel free to follow up
thank you
the the first thing i would just note on
you know you
a claimant could end up
hitting the cap with
with only
five or six
of the of the worst incidents or even
four or four of the worst incidents
because they might also have additional
incidents of um
i i hesitate to use the word less severe
abuse but let's just say abuse that
falls in a different place scientific
facts that a claimant or a victim would
bring bring to this process so that's
that's just the first thing i would note
you know you certainly don't have to get
to 10 and have a multiplier of 12 to hit
the cap depending on what
what incidence
or what types of abuse
you're alleging
um
i
we have some information on the average
length of stay i think which would show
that say prior to 10 years ago the
average length was a lot higher than
seven months and i might even
ask
senior assistant attorney general ramsey
to come up to talk about that a little
bit because i
i do think we have we have some of that
info so
so i do think that that longer duration
would come into play given that many of
these claimants were from long enough
ago when the average length of stay was
longer we've seen that length of stay
come down over time and in recent years
especially the last 10 the average
length is
is a lot lower but if you start to go
back in time you'd see that the average
lengths of stay at ydc where we're a lot
longer
you could share that with us because
absolutely director ribson told me that
his information only went back to 2011.
yep we can absolutely share that
and
then
on
you know a higher value for a longer
duration
again there's no there's no what i would
say is a correct way to value these
things you know we try to take into
account the research that's available we
take into account our discussions with
claimants counsel
but i think the reasoning for
for valuing
incidents at a higher level or at least
having an aggravating factor if they
occur over a longer period of time
there i think there's research to show
that if
especially a child if if if they suffer
even if they suffer the same incidence
of abuse if that
occurs over a longer period of time so
it doesn't occur say within two months
and then it's done
it occurs once
and then it occurs again a couple months
later
again a couple months later again a
couple months later that that
that often is is more harmful and causes
um
longer lasting
trauma or a different type and a more
significant type of trauma again there's
no though perfect uh there's no exact
science to this because every person is
different
and
every victim is impacted differently by
the harm they suffer
so
i wish i could tell you that we made
that change and it would work perfectly
and it perfectly fits every single
victim i think on the whole
it's a change that is warranted because
on the whole if you play this out over
over an entire population of victims
there is research to show that the
trauma is worse if it occurs repeatedly
over a longer period of time
so that that was the reasoning for that
but i do acknowledge that
um there's no exact science to this and
that every
you know it
every victim
the harm plays out in different ways for
that victim and the impact is is
different
but 12 months is the
magic
line
i i wouldn't say it's a magic line i
would say it's our best attempt at
at drawing a line but i would never sit
here and tell you i think that's that's
a magic line
thank you and finally
i share representative lynn's concern
about the
um
this
process and the way it contemplates
gender
and anatomy
so because
boy's anatomy makes it
more likely that
the assault would be category c for
masturbation
rather than um
the anal or genital rape or oral rape
there are so many more boys
at the sununu center that
the a and b
awards for boys are
less likely
to occur
and the higher awards
for girls are less likely to occur but
i'm not sure
that the victims turn experience of
trauma
is
different and matches up with
the distinctions on monetary award and i
wonder if you could just comment on that
i think again the best response i can
give to that is you know we've we've
just arrived at these distinctions based
on the various research that's available
and then the conversations we've we've
had with
with all involved
i think as i said to representative lin
you know i think there's there's room
for the administrator to take that into
account
and there is certainly room for the
administrator who will be
an even more objective third party
neutral in this process to take a look
at that
listen to what claimants counsel may
have to say on that front and if the
administrator determines that
they should come back and request a
change to that
the administrator will be able to do
yes senator susie thank you madam chair
um good morning i don't apologize i'm
sitting in for senator d'alessandro so i
wasn't at the previous meeting although
i did
refer to um the handouts and and
certainly have reviewed them but i did
have two questions one was about um
your characterization of trauma-informed
and a victim-centered process
and i wondered if in designing the
program you had consulted anyone um
beyond those
advocacy groups or
victim advocates
that are not employed by your office
have you gone beyond just the office
so
certainly as the legislation was going
was going through the process we
consulted with with a number of outside
the legislation contemplates
really negotiating and discussing this
process with claimants counsel and and
our
victim witness advocates within the
department of justice
you know i will say our our victim
witness advocates work with with all of
these outside groups and they do
they do
an enormous amount of amazing work with
all these groups and i think they
they're in a very good position to to
provide feedback
that
takes into account
the feedback that many of these groups
would provide we also um
again looked at outside research and and
other sources
we
did not
you know have extensive discussions with
with uh with outside groups beyond our
victim witness advocates again because
they were they work with all these
groups they're in a great position to
to take that type of information into
account and also because that's what was
contemplated by the legislation
okay and then i just have one additional
question if i may and this one is about
sort of the i think
i would view as a challenge but within
the department of justice the role of
having to
defend the state on the criminal side in
these cases and then also prosecuting on
the civil side and my question is about
how you segregate information
so you've gained information at this
point i'm sure through discovery on the
criminal side that's informed the
process i'm wondering how you would
protect claimant information that might
be involved in other cases
even if it's unrelated to this process
and if you've contemplated going forward
any segregation for that information of
the claimants yeah
so
within the department of justice we have
very strict walls that are
that are in place between
the criminal side of this process and
the civil side of this process and
generally
obviously i as the attorney general have
access to both and i try
and it's just a challenge every attorney
general has had to confront over the
years you know i have to be very
disciplined and do my best not to let
that information
cross the walls
the determination has been made and it's
always been the office's practice that
ultimately the attorney general is the
one who has to make
the decisions at the top level and
resolve conflicts so so they have to
have access to both sides but but the
information really is segregated and and
neither side has access to the other
side's information
the caveat to that is that defendants in
a criminal case have
have of course certain rights to access
information that may be exculpatory and
relevant to their case so
i wish i could sit here and tell you
that i know exactly how that's going to
play out in cases where we've charged
we've brought criminal charges
i don't i don't know exactly what
information may ultimately have to make
its way into a criminal case but
but we will certainly do everything we
can
to keep any sensitive information
um
that
that could cause harm to a claimant if
it became public to keep it
keep it private we'll do everything we
can within the confines of a defendant's
constitutional rights on the criminal
side
we'll have many many claimants for whom
we cannot bring criminal charges and so
we won't have that dynamic in which
there's a criminal case that's relevant
to their allegations going on at the
same time that they might be either
bringing a claim through this process or
or pursuing their claims in in court but
but the best answer i can give is that
we have strict walls within the
department to segregate the information
and that while
some of that information may have to
cross over in a criminal case based on
the requirements that that exculpatory
information be provided to a criminal
defendant we'll do everything we
possibly can to to keep sensitive
information private
and could i just ask one follow-up to to
that point um general formella
would you see a scenario where perhaps
the administrator once appointed and
into their responsibilities might come
before this committee or
recommend additional legislation to try
to
further ensure privacy for claimants so
that that line is
a little bit brighter
sure i could envision that especially as
this process begins to get set up and
implemented and the administrator gets
their arms around it that that could be
the type of thing the administrator
comes back to this committee or or
brings forward recommendations to the
legislature on thank you
or this committee requests his presence
or her presence right i don't want to
make an assumption uh representative
edwards you had a question uh uh thank
you madam chair and uh i'm gonna i'm
gonna basically leap frog off of what
senator soucy just said um and and take
this in a little bit different direction
uh than the rest of the questions have
been but as i as i look at section 310
the document 310 page six
at the bottom of that there's a a very
nice
concise executive summary of the legal
notice dash privacy and confidentiality
and i i i view this this write-up
as being necessary but perhaps not
sufficient
and so
i'm i'm i'm curious
particularly listening to the response
to senator susie's questions
about the sharing of information within
the department
whether or not
there should be an explicit written
privacy policy which is the way we did
it in the corporate world we would write
a privacy policy that was probably
multiple pages in length and one of the
things that we would touch upon in a
privacy policy
is um the the extent to which sharing
would uh of the data within the company
between third-party agencies uh could be
done or had to be protected and stopped
right so there's a sharing component of
it that i think doc or doctor excuse me
uh senator susie has touched on
then there are two other parts
that just jump out at me as things that
you might find in a privacy policy
um
one would be
the individual who's filed a claim
what rights do they have to
request the termination of their claim
and the deletion and destruction of any
information that they had provided to
the state it's basically in europe it's
referred to as the right to be forgotten
and i'm just curious if we've
anticipated that we might ever have a
claimant want to just withdraw and have
any state knowledge of what they've
provided uh destroyed so that that's the
second aspect and then the third um
typically in a in a privacy policy it'll
state specifically what a retention
period might be um
how long will this information be
retained by the state
you know 10 years after the settlement
20 years after the settlement at some
point we should be able to put a stake
in the ground and say after this date
this information this is the type of
information that shall be destroyed now
certainly there's probably always going
to be some component of the information
that needs to be retained but
parts of it
that can be expunged and destroyed ought
to be as a matter of
programmatic policy so so again i want
to come back and i want to say this is a
really nice executive summary of the
privacy and confidentiality
limits or rules of engagement
and and i'm just curious the extent that
there's a
maybe a supplemental uh
privacy policy that's uh broader and
so
i think to the extent that we're talking
about you know the sharing of
information within the department of
justice we we have very routine just
sort of procedures on on how we handle
how we handle that when someone is
okay i i just in the interest of time i
i just want to keep the question
simpler which is
d do you do you see that there's a need
for
another document around the privacy
issues that are broader and deeper than
this statement on page six it's kind of
more of a yes or no and then there's
plenty of time to talk details but um
yes i think there certainly could be
room for that i would just note without
taking up too much time i promise that
we we discussed this in the legislative
process and i know there's
there was a balance between the need to
maintain privacy and also
maintain generally the the access to
to records of all of this that the
public may have an interest in and i
think this this is based on that balance
we ultimately arrived at the legislation
but but i think yes this will warrant
further and i think continuing
conversation as this process plays out
thank you
um mr attorney general
while i was sitting here we received a
letter
from commissioner hanks
and in her letter i've been trying to
skim it really quickly in her letter she
brings up a couple of concerns um
one about um that they at the
prison they cannot use internet for
filing
these claims and the other being around
the phone system
used by the residents at the prisons and
that they
would only be able to make collect
collect calls
and i wondered if you had
discussed with her how you will
proceed with those two issues
yes so so the collect calls piece i
think we can certainly work with the
administrator on that to
to um
and charge the administrator with
working with the department of
corrections to to facilitate um
facilitate a resident's ability to make
calls to the administrator so i i think
we certainly will we can work with both
the administrator and the department of
corrections on that
on the access to the internet piece
i i think i mentioned earlier in my
remarks
you know i'm not sure there's a way to
to alter that policy on residents not
having access to the internet
but
you know we certainly are willing to and
will you know discuss with the
department of corrections discuss with
the administrator once that person is
appointed whether there's some other way
to enable a resident to interact with
this process electronically i don't know
if there will be but if there is a way
to do it that that doesn't
raise concerns of the department of
corrections and that is possible will
will certainly do it so i i'm committed
thank you yes go thank you i wondered if
um commissioner hanks has would want to
say anything about these two areas of
i don't know if it's morning so maybe
good afternoon or good morning thank you
for that opportunity for the record uh
helen hanks commissioner of the
department of corrections and thank you
for those um two specific questions the
internet will be a challenge because of
our requirement to meet what's called
sieges criminal justice information
system requirements and not allowing
people who are incarcerated onto our
internet we do not have a separate
resident network and then we have
a significant number of individuals
incarcerated for
offenses
excuse me sexual offenses who have
computer access prohibited as part of
their sentencing document
um
we can find a path forward i'm sure i'm
not sure it will be through the internet
um and we do have individuals who
obviously are filing claims on a daily
basis and we do have notaries and we are
still
helping them process paper
and so that is the fastest most
efficient way but to ask
correctional staff for example to then
be a steward to file e-claims would put
i think both the claimant and the
employee in an awkward situation so i do
think access to the internet will be a
challenge if there was a
hypothetical conversation around a legal
liaison we could set up an office space
and give that person as a steward to the
administrator
access to the internet but we want to
make sure that the person facilitating
internet access has control of the
internet and is an impartial third party
to the process
so that's the first response i would
make with regard to the internet
the uh phone system
uh been trying to come
contemplate a solution to that because
certainly we do not want to create an
impediment to contacting the
administrator um and as we allow
individuals to have attorney calls um
i'm working with our current vendor on
what that might look like to create a
here is the phone number here's a point
to point access on the phone system that
does not allow for a charge on either
party
so i i think that is the something that
we can overcome and establish a plan
with the goj and the administrator on
that point so i hope that provides some
additional information
and certainly willing to answer any
senator roosevelt you have a question i
do thank you commissioner hanks
or general formella if you had
discussion with the county houses of
corrections
to see if they
good access to notaries and
telephones even collect as
the state
facilities
senator roosevelt certainly i have not
um i know some information about who
have similar systems and who do not but
we have not but we could certainly do
that
thank you senator rosenwald that was one
of my questions as well
because
yeah we we did not discuss at all
the county uh correctional facilities
and i think that
we need to make sure that uh that that's
included
okay i do have
two questions
besides that one
first of all i notice that you are
identifying one granite place
as the place for the
administrator
are you going to be in that building by
then or is the administrator going to
live there all by him or herself
well i think right now the courts are
over there so so that yeah so i don't
know if we'll be in there by then but
we'll be in there eventually but given
that the administrative office of the
courts is over there that's why the
administrator is going to be there
because they're working in the judicial
branch okay fine i just
that was good news to me actually thank
you
and my other question is is that we had
talked about um
putting the claim form up on the web
with a fill in the blank
kind of thing
it will be progressing
yes okay we've had discussions with with
okay so you're hoping to have that done
by the first of december
or before
certainly i think january 1 is when the
claims window opens so certainly by the
time the claims
window opens on january one yes okay
okay
seeing no further questions
i would entertain
emotion to approve fis 307
and add the comment that the ag
can correct typos
in the document without coming back to
thank you second
chair
yes
to that motion about correcting the
typos it would seem prudent that they
should either get reviewed by
the chair or approved by the chair
um
as a matter of course just so that there
is a connection with with this committee
i was wondering if that modification the
motion can be made it's certainly a
decision made between approval
or
notification okay i have i have no
problem with that
i love this document i've read it so
many times i
is there any further discussion
senator bradley
uh thank you very much madam chair i
think that this is a very reasonable way
to
move forward
i appreciate in particular the changes
to the multiplier as i think that
um
really
solidifies the the process and the
document i think it's also important and
we haven't really discussed the letters
that we've received but going back to
when um representative umberger filed
the legislation
i don't think it ever was envisioned
that this was going to work for
absolutely everybody that there were
still some claims that were going to um
go forward through the court system and
so i go back to the letters that we've
received and i think it it bears note
that um
the letters talk about the fact that
and these are from the attorneys that
represent some of the claimants that
um
some of the issues have been resolved by
the process and so that's you know
obviously to your credit and to the
credit of
the attorney some of whom were here
today
but they also talk about that it's a
fair way and i'm going from
tony scalimbrini's letter a fair way to
resolve liability for many but not all
of the children that were abused by
the state authority that is consistent i
think with the process that was outlined
in the legislature and then also mr
rainbow's letter
um
says something very similar we strongly
believe that if the administered
is efficiently and equitably a large
majority
of the claimants will strongly favor the
program for two main factors time
and process so i think
while
no legislation this included is ever
perfect for everybody
it's it's a very reasonable way of
proceeding i think it's also important
that we've heard
from
not only yourself but
in the conversations that you've had
with some of the claimant attorneys a
process for choosing the administrator
that's going to be
very important and i think the
commitment
that's been made today that the
administrator
can come forward either to the fiscal
committee or potential even the full
legislature
um with possible changes based on you
know what happens i think is also
effective so i think you know
you've done a really good job i think
you know i want to
give a shout out to tony scalimbrini and
a couple of the other attorneys that
worked long and hard with your office
with miss ramsey
so i think it's a reasonable way to
proceed and hopefully bring closure for
a number of people that
just having to rely on the court system
is is not going to work for them because
of what was outlined in terms of time
and process so
i am pleased to second center daniel's
motion
okay
i think you have to third it
because
okay representative lynn
i think
i heard that in my ear but that's okay
okay are there any further discussion
seeing none will the clerk call the role
hamrick votes yes
representative irf yes
representative lynn
representative daniels yes
representative senator bradley yes
senator gray yes
senator rosenwald no
senator
susie no
representative
yes
madam sure the vote is seven yes three
no
with the vote of seven in favor and
three opposed fis 307 8
9 and 10
pass
so
i would i would like to just say that um
i know and i think we all know that uh
if we had
a million years
to try to get this process absolutely
perfect
we might make it
uh we've had roughly three months
and i do want to stress
that
the person that is appointed as
administrator
we'll re-look at this
see if there are things that he or she
thinks need to be adjusted
and
and we're
open at any time on the fiscal committee
for the administrator to return
but i truly thank
the ag's office
for all of the hard work and
uh both in preparing the legislation
as well as preparing the process
and i know that uh
you and jennifer have spent
untold hours in trying to to get this to
the point where it is today
so i i truly thank you
and um
[Music]
people
in ydc that have been
abused this is
another step forward
without spending
time and money trying to go through
uh the court
and um
as i think we all understand
if
the people go through the court
we're looking at
probably years and years
before that process can be completed
but for those that
feel very strongly that this process the
this alternative process is not going to
work for them then yes they should in
fact go to court
but i thank you and i thank all of the
the folks on the fiscal committee
and i will see you friday
for our you're going to see us yeah some
of us have pre-fiscal
yeah for our regular fiscal committee
meeting and i know that general formella
will be back
and i know that commissioner hanks will
be back so
i look forward to
seeing you all on friday
and fiscal is adjourned
you